y ahora hablamos de economía porque hay
varias noticias importantes en la
jornada de hoy está con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches tenemos que comenzar en Estados
Unidos porque las autoridades de este
país anunciaron un paquete de medidas
para esta emergencia para disipar todos
estos temores en torno a la salud del
sistema financiero y bancario de Estados
Unidos después del colapso de estos dos
bancos bueno hubo muchísimo movimiento
los bonos estadounidenses repuntaron
también los índices bursátiles
recuperaron de sus mínimos pero sin duda
los más afectados fueron estos bancos
regionales estadounidenses y te voy a
dar algunos ejemplos de ellos las
acciones de Twitter Republic Band
cayeron un 62% la de Western aliens
bancorp un 47% y la de pack West vancore
un 21% sufriendo múltiples
interrupciones en la cotización estas
medidas que incluyen garantizar el
dinero de todos los depositantes y
facilitar las condiciones de los
préstamos a los bancos necesitados de
liquidez pueden no ser suficiente según
los expertos para proteger a los bancos
en un futuro la deuda financiera con
grado de inversión cayó Mientras que el
riesgo crediticio de las empresas
estadounidenses también se disparó a
máximos de cuatro meses ahora los
expertos creen que lo sucedido hará que
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos no
sea tan agresiva y que se plantee
incluso pausar las subidas de los tipos
de interés hasta que los mercados se
estabilicen Aunque el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden intentó
tranquilizar a los mercados y aseguró
que el sistema bancario de su país es
seguro y las bolsas de todo el mundo
registraron fuertes caídas biden habló
después de que las autoridades
financieras estadounidenses anunciaran
el domingo que garantizarán todos los
depósitos del silicon cuya quiebra
amenazaba con arrastrar a otras
entidades financieras regionales y
también crear de alguna forma una crisis
de confianza en todo el sistema bancario
de Estados Unidos la reserva federal y
el departamento del tesoro dijeron que
además de respaldar los depósitos de
este banco crearán un nuevo mecanismo de
préstamos para los bancos que puedan
verse afectados por a oleada de demandas
de retirada de fondos de parte de sus
clientes bueno con todo este remesón en
el sistema financiero entonces veamos
los indicadores de la jornada empezamos
en Estados Unidos ahí las acciones de
los bancos mundiales y los rendimientos
también de los bonos del tesoro
estadounidense a corto plazo cayeron el
dólar También cayó el oro y la plata
subieron gracias a la a estas compras de
refugio en Europa la bolsas registraron
el este lunes un mayor caída diaria del
año arrastradas por los valores
bancarios a pesar de las intervenciones
de las autoridades para limitar las
consecuencias de la repentina quiebra de
El silicon y en América Latina hubo
cautela frente a las consecuencias de
esta quiebra del banco estadounidense y
el desplome de acciones como la de la
petrolera estatal petrova que empujaron
al B3 a su tercera caída consecutiva
pasemos Entonces ahora a ver otro banco
que también estaba en problemas y
colapso que es el signature Bank porque
el silicon Valley Bank no fue que
reportó ya el cierre de operaciones
bueno el banco daba herramientas para
facilitar las transacciones digitales y
entre sus clientes había notables
empresas de criptomonedas como coinbase
este banco hace parte de un grupo
reducido de bancos convencionales que
atienden las necesidades de las empresas
de criptomonedas un sector que también
se vio alterado tras el cierre de El
silvergate capital un banco que cerró
justamente el miércoles pasado el
colapso de Signal fue provocado en parte
por la caída de silicon vallebank pocos
bancos estaban tan integrados en las
empresas de criptomoneda como signature
y silvergate y su caída es un golpe
simbólico para este sector la decisión
de cerrar signature fue una sorpresa
para sus directivos al igual que silicon
con una clientela formada casi
exclusivamente por empresas signature
tenía una base de depósitos en su
mayoría no asegurada aproximadamente el
90% de los depósitos de signature y más
del 93% de los depósitos
de silicon Valle van también era algo
que tenía en común estos dos bancos que
no los tenían asegurados esto pudo
llamar la atención de los reguladores
que estudien ahora los bancos con
grandes bases de depósitos no asegurados
bueno la pregunta del millón Jorge Por
qué estos dos bancos se quebraron tan
rápido porque en el mercado y en los
últimos días no vimos señales de
problemas para llegar a la bancarrota
Bueno antes de responderte Hay que decir
que en los últimos 23 años han quebrado
566 bancos en Estados Unidos pero la
mayor parte de ellos fue durante la
crisis financiera las quiebras de
signature Bank y también de silicon
Valley fueron dos de las tres mayores de
la historia bancaria de Estados Unidos
tras el colapso de Washington en el año
2008 Aunque el tipo de riesgo más común
al que se enfrenta un banco es un
aumento de los impagos de los préstamos
lo que se conoce como riesgo de crédito
eso no es lo que ocurrió aquí aquí
entrando factores en juego primero el
riesgo de los tipos de interés y segundo
el riesgo de liquidez primero blanco se
enfrenta al riesgo de tipos de interés
Cuando esto suben rápidamente Y eso está
ocurriendo en Estados Unidos desde marzo
del 2022 la reserva Federal de ese país
ha estado subiendo los tipos de interés
de forma agresiva los llevó hasta de 0 a
4,5 puntos porcentuales para tratar de
controlar la inflación eso provocó que
el rendimiento de los bonos del tesoro
que es ese mecanismo donde vos prestas
dinero al gobierno y te lo devuelven
determinado plazo con intereses tocó su
nivel más alto en 17 años el 5,26% en
marzo Cuando sube el rendimiento de un
valor su precio baja por eso una subida
tan rápida de los tipos de interés
provocó un desplome del valor de Mercado
de la deuda emitida ya sean bonos
corporativos o letras del tesoro el
silicon tenía una gran parte de sus
activos el 55% invertido en valores de
renta fija Como esos bonos del gobierno
estadounidense entonces decidió vender
veintiún mil millones en valores de su
cartera con una pérdida de 1800 millones
de dólares eso llevó Santiago el segundo
problema el riesgo de liquidez los
clientes del banco estaban retirando sus
depósitos por encima de lo que el banco
podía pagar utilizando su efectivo y
para responderle a la gente el banco
decide hacer una emisión de acciones
para recaudar más de 2.500 millones de
dólares y esa petición de fondos hizo
que los clientes perdieran la confianza
en el banco y se apresuraran a retirar
todo su efectivo esto se conoce como una
corrida bancaria algo que puede provocar
la quiebra de cualquier banco saludable
en cuestión de días especialmente en
nuestros tiempos de la era digital Jorge
Pues excelente explicación no nos toca
ver un documental en Netflix para
entenderlo Muchas gracias por ponernos
al tanto en torno a este tema a
continuación en directo América el
debate
[Música]